sam askari is showing his support for
his girlfriend
britney spears we're a family ahead of
britney's latest hearing for her ongoing
conservatorship battle on wednesday
sam took to his insta story to share
this snap
rocking a shirt with the words free
britney painted in pink and purple
writing
the shirt is in support of the hashtag
free britney movement
a hashtag that was created by fans and
is used by those who claim that the pop
star is being held against her will
and is trying to call for help through
her social media posts
sam also added a lion emoji at the top
of his post
fans of the couple know that the fitness
expert often refers to his girlfriend
as his lioness she's a sweetheart and i
think that no matter what they're going
to know that she's a sweetheart
the post comes on wednesday just hours
before the performer is expected to
address the los angeles court directly
e.t confirmed earlier this month that
due to covid19 protocols brittany would
appear remotely
not in person for the hearing this will
mark the first time in years that
brittany will speak
in court about the conservatorship which
she's been in since 2008.
this is very important that she's
decided to speak out now and i think
she's doing it because
basically she's come to a head and she
needs to figure out
what she's going to do about this
conservatorship and she thinks
this is the best way to get her point
across
earlier this week the new york times
reported that they obtained confidential
court records
that revealed the toxic singer has been
quietly pushing for years to end her
conservatorship
according to the outlet brittany
expressed quote serious opposition to
the conservatorship
earlier and more often than had
previously been known in the court
records
and claimed that it restricted
everything from whom she dated to the
color of her kitchen cabinets
per the new york times a court
investigator wrote in a 2016 report
quote she articulated she feels the
conservatorship has become an oppressive
and controlling tool against her
adding that brittany informed them that
she wanted the conservatorship
terminated as soon as possible quote she
is sick of being taken advantage of
and she said she is the one working and
earning her money but
everyone around her is on her payroll on
wednesday et spoke to the president of
law and crime network rachel
stockman who explained why it's so
important for brittany to speak in court
addressing the court does have the
impact on the judge
and the case it's always extremely
important to hear from the person
directly involved and whether you
believe it or not whether the attorneys
go back and forth
emotions in court it always makes a big
impact when you hear from the person
herself
i don't think it's necessarily a big
deal in your average
conservatorship hearing if the
conservative decides to speak out
however
this is not your average case this is
involving a
huge celebrity so i think it's a very
big deal that she's speaking out and
she has told the court she wants her
voice heard
[Music]